hello and welcome to the new world
review I'm Grandal and waifu and it is
time for some more discussion about
hunter hunter
do you like frosty chocolate milkshakes
do you like the Internet
do you like appraising art do you love
the image of gone being hit across the
back of the head what rent do I have
some spoilers for you let's have a
thumbs up for milkshakes and making
friends with those who have weird
eyebrows even if they're somewhat creepy
I threw out blame Sanji anyway this
isn't a one piece review it's a hunter
hunter review so let's get into episodes
48 and 49 episode 48 while karateka
buries his enemy face down in an
unmarked grave somewhere where no one
would ever find him anyway and he was
under no obligation to do so because
crows would come out and pick up the
eyes eat the skin and possibly the leech
eggs before anyone could actually find
him gone killer and Lyari are back at
the internet cafe I understand both that
they are supposed to be the comic relief
and that they're supposed to be
fulfilling a different function but this
episode felt more than a little bit
aimless there was a lot of information
that as of yet doesn't have anywhere to
go
I now know a lot more about appraising
artifacts than I ever needed or wanted
to and there is a great deal of filler
in what was said God wants to learn how
to appraise things so they can go
through all the information they've had
in one scene a second time seemingly
just a fill time and to note while
korabik is having his emotional time
here's what the others are doing based
on the time of day it seems the Phantom
troupe have decided to stay in the city
since we know that who Govan is in fact
dead and not coming back I'm still
unsure as to whether the leader of the
troupe wants to find him to kill him or
to invite him into the troupe
particularly given the fact that to get
in you have to kill a previous member am
I getting that wrong have I made up my
own law maybe anyway back to the less
interesting episode that I just watched
I found the episode somewhat fun and
enjoyable to watch but less interesting
while I started out intently watching
and trying to take information in like a
few other episodes that have come up
during this show it felt like
information for informations sake kind
of a well we need to shove this lore
into the animated show somehow here it
is and while it may become incredibly
relevant in an episode or two the fact
that I feel this way about it suggests
that it came from so far left of field
that my audience I couldn't see the
relevance of 20 minutes spent on it
beyond meetings they feel I truly think
he will be important to know of at some
point but I don't know
it's now and I don't know that it makes
sense here and it's conflicting though
right because on the one hand why should
I care about the bidding process and the
searching or hunting down of artifacts
to make a quick buck but on the other
this is literally what the ark was
supposed to be about to some degree this
banality that gone in kill are
experiencing is exactly what would have
been happening if something else didn't
get in the way in this arc they get to
be for some of it anyway
ordinary and I suppose I really need to
note that to go from intensity to
intensity would be desensitizing over
time so hey let's learn about how to buy
and sell in this world of auctioning
despite the fact that we don't have
anything to sell at the moment because
the phantom troupe took it all which is
a point of confusion for me actually
that I've probably skimmed over
somewhere how can these three know
everyone's tracking down the Phantom
troupe without even vaguely considering
or looking up why come on kill while
you're supposed to be the intelligent
one in this particular crowd you hear
information and you spent the entire
hunter exam showing you had insight and
intelligence where is it and why aren't
you using it I mean you didn't always
have insight but in this particular area
you really should within the oddity of
this episode there were moments of
interest that struck me why doesn't the
audio have more knowledge of nen why is
he so far behind is he aware that he
hasn't actually finished his hunter exam
as yet as one of my notes states no Gil
Forli Oriole and so fear since we left
lay audio again and met another hyper
emotional character immediately what is
it with anime or manga that Liam thinks
I should consume and these particular
eyebrows what is it he's trying to tell
me do I need those eyebrows does he want
me to draw those eyebrows on him does he
want me to do it while he's sleeping I
guess I'll have to find out and report
back
Zef ear at first is a very angry man
unreasonably angry given the
conversation amounted to my dear man you
are wrong for there is perhaps that he
severe no no not an adhesive but as
allies cut out of it
ah but again you are wrong for the
answer is that it's a perfectly normal
piece of art but with riches inside
don't you fight me
I am the knower of arts and riches now
give me the art that I wanted in the
first place but for to claim for these
children look I'll even cut it open and
this entire exchange was absurd and
while it was great to be as bemused as
Kiowa and gone particularly since we
watched everything from their
perspective we were again in
undated with the deep inner worlds of
even more new people I haven't learned
all the people I'm supposed to be
dealing with now why did they feel do
this why did he do it
because he could sense aura he could
sense gone and couldn't appraise him
does that sound a little creepy to you I
mean people find hisoka's Schwing allen
creepy but the idea that there's a man
who wanders the markets trying to
appraise people for their value reminds
me of the child catcher from Chitty
Chitty Bang Bang the idea that he
follows them around just to appraise a
preteen is very very strange to me even
stranger than finding it arousing that
the preteen shows potential as a
combatant does anyone else find it odd
in other news that kilowatt just keeps
giving away gone secrets he's just so
happy to tell everyone who asks about
gone and why he's on his personal quest
without disclosing anything about
himself as barter fuel it's happened a
few times now and every time it really
concerns me for some reason this was
also the first time I wondered whether
Gaughan would end up being like Hisoka
down the line he became very passionate
when Zephie downplayed his counterfeits
almost to the point of yelling you will
do this and grow because you can and
because I said so and I am gone the
Magnificent Vaughn seems to be very
intent on people learning to live to
their potential and while that shouldn't
surprise me it's a bug on my wall does
surprise man there is now not a bug on
my wall gone seems to be very intent on
people learning to live to their
potential and while that shouldn't
surprise me it does a little what
purpose does it serve gone to have
someone show that potential and why
didn't it concerns their fear that gone
obviously doesn't care about right or
wrong has gone found his perfect art
mate he seems to be collecting men who
show more interest in him than they
should at his age not in general you
know you do you
bing-bong as the two of them just
literally leave everything with this guy
they just met and go running it's time
for us to take a look at episode the
next it's been a big week I don't know
where we are
49 huh okay let's take a look at this
number episode of 49 the overall energy
of it was a beautiful suspense and we
got to a fantastic place but let's go
from the start given how much shade I
threw at Keele WA because I'm about to
throw some more Kiawah if you knew that
the Phantom troop would dangerous why
didn't you say anything to them before
how as an assassin
yes a child assassin but as an assassin
could you underestimate them so poorly
and how could you not consider that
others would or could be following this
group - there's a lot of kilwa blunder
in this episode and while I'm not a
killer assassin kid I feel like the
crucial information from his dad that
it's too much effort to kill a member of
the troupe was information that really
he should have mentioned earlier I just
don't understand why he a didn't tell
them and be thought it was a good idea
to follow that said if he hadn't decided
to follow thanks to lay Oreos prodding
don't think I don't see you there Laurie
Oh failing to be useful while egging on
the little ones you go and hide yeah
sure marches hunches against Nobunaga's
logical thinking was a terrifying thing
to watch not least because it's sort of
what happens in my own head except
noisier and less organized picture if
you will both of these characters in my
head but making a lot of noise and with
the occasional Hisoka swing passing
through sound fun it should some wid
stuff goes on in my head Marchese head
though the use of instinct is very clear
and concise sitting at a table in the
open then wandering to another open
space they very easily caught the two
kids except they didn't did they
breast 'ok you'll and [ __ ] boy caught
them because they were also trailing the
bait to see who followed the fact that
they assume it's crap occur or people
could a pack ascent to follow is a
really huge and awkward coincidence and
the reason those two doofuses are alive
right now is that they don't realize
it's could i picker the trooper looking
for that they want to catch karapa cadet
or alive and have decided by the flip of
a coin whether to do so is fascinating
as is the fact that much he wants to
capture him alive while Nobunaga wants
him dead is interesting information to
file away soon however karappa kawin
left of the Hitman sent to capture or
kill on behalf of the mafia and when he
gets there he may be somewhat surprised
oh can we briefly return to that
restaurant and the milkshakes for a
moment not just because Liam really
likes milkshakes but because of the
concept of two hisoka's now can we
cross-reference that with the end frame
of all of the troops sitting there and
waiting to meet their new kid friends
now replace all of them with Hisoka ah
that's better
neons next on the hit list likely not to
be killed because her power is too
useful but maybe to be lured away from
her family I understand why crawler
would go after her and to be clear
that's what I got from the interaction
since it seems he told shale nook to
locate karateka while he dealt with the
Nostra family since she's desperate for
a mummy that may be easy
to achieve melody is about to be split
from Copic again I do wonder whether
she's okay with this or if it's
something she'll try to fight in some
way they would probably go against her
needs to fight against it and crop occur
with likely not let her but I'm still
hmm he hasn't checked his phone for the
others as yet or if he has he hasn't
replied and doesn't care which reminds
me the other two have his number they
called him I wonder whether that will
come into play next episode or if the
many iterations of his Soaker will
instead maybe they'll give themselves
away once they seen him sitting up in
that corner but we didn't have that
reveal at the end of this episode so I
can't wait to see it at the beginning of
the next question tool actually why did
kilwa hit gone that's something I've
been trying to figure out is it because
Kiawah didn't know how gone had
completed that challenge was it because
Gahan had done something so dangerous
but managed to hide from his Sokka what
does it say about the rest of the
Phantom troop that Gahan could hide from
his soca during the exam but failed to
hide from the rest of them now it's such
an interesting conundrum - who says that
and the end of the episode I adored it
when I say and I mean the second half
really going in to kill waz mind meant
that we weren't considering who might be
behind though while he was in the bush I
did flashback to Gahan sitting in the
bush while hunting his Soaker and
thought but what if someone's watching
him it says a lot about how perspective
and framing can influence audience
thought process actually because up to
then I hadn't considered it and with the
amount of suspense in the long carefully
constructed frames of this moment I
forgot again until it was too late
in that moment I froze just like gon and
killua I understood every response to
being trapped that he had I went with
him on that desperate journey to escape
the cuts and close-ups and now I think
I'm definitely seeing some animation
changes to accommodate what is more
ambitious ideas to be communicated
desperation fear panic kill WA
experienced all of those immediately
gone started to but then didn't get a
chance to fully express it or didn't
want to hmm it was a beautiful dichotomy
especially since kill why is the trained
assassin and gone is the new kid to see
how each child handled extreme pressure
was something I didn't know I needed to
have but now I do and I'm grateful and
since I got what I needed and what I
wanted that's it from me this week I'm
really looking forward to next episode
if you are to hit the like and subscribe
buttons click here and
and there and maybe somewhere over there
come and hang out in the discord have a
cookie and I'll see you next time
oh and a milkshake have a milkshake too
my